hi guys I'm Vanessa and this is my
husband hi guys Gabriel and we just
moved into this new apartment it came
fully furnished but we want to make it
our own we wanted to make it a little
bit more cozy and I don't know homey
[Music]
so this place came with a lot of things
we have a sofa we have some tables we
have a little cute coffee table and we
have this big bean bag which is
interesting it's kind of like a bean bag
but it also has a bean bag yeah ottoman
yeah yeah so it's like a matching Duo
like it's customizable which I guess is
nice but as soon as you sit on it and it
compresses you kind of like sink down
into it to the ground not not
particularly ideal so since this is a
rental we want to make it like our own
but we can't do like a huge
transformation but I feel like we can
really judge it up I feel like I have
been on Pinterest like way too much I
have a Pinterest board of like what I
Envision and like what design style I
like I think sometimes we differ yeah I
feel like you like a lot of decorations
yeah and I like a more minimal style of
things yeah and also like everything you
like is beige beautiful and beige that's
my tagline so our challenge today is to
make it you know beautiful for both of
us because you like more minimal I like
a beige Palace so we're gonna combine it
and hopefully we can both be happy in
this
all right so we're gonna get started the
first thing that needs to go is our
lovely friend Mr Bean Bag squishy friend
yeah and his homie right here and we
have to move our little coffee table
okay so I think the fireplace should be
the focal point and I really love our
window but it's kind of getting blocked
by the sofa so what do you think if we
move the sofa over here
I mean we can try it I know you're a
minimalist but keep an open mind okay I
found this rug what do you say we could
try it okay great so this looks cute and
now we can put the coffee table on top
he doesn't seem so convinced guys all
right so in this corner we have a couple
things that I think should go I'm not a
huge fan of this little guy although
it's practical it has storage but I mean
but it doesn't really serve yeah and
it's empty
yeah it has nothing in it it doesn't go
with the vibe and this is another guy
that I don't like but you love yeah I
mean so it's kind of a bit of an oddball
piece but I like it if you like it then
we'll keep it so yeah you gotta press
the vision I I will trust the vision now
I would like to put these chairs which
have a more simple approach more sort of
in the minimalist theme I love the
little holes on them gives a more sort
of like a visual interest and I think
they'll look great here with the new
window and all the light that's coming
in I like it I like your vision I have
this mirror that we had in our room and
I think it would look really nice here
it like opens up the space it looks
really nice so this is not actually a
table but I saw this hack where you can
get a stand like this
and a planter basket flip it around oh
what and there you go doesn't that look
so cool yeah it's like a makeshift table
I love it so this is actually a gift
from our neighbor it could work there
like I I can see the vision that's
beautiful wow nice little like almost
Reading area yeah
okay so we have this really nice mantel
and I feel like we can put a lot of
decorations around it especially since I
Really Love candles so I think this one
looked really cool top of this and this
right here it's like functional but also
beautiful yeah I think candles really
add the coziness feel you know that I
really like plants and I have a lot of
them everywhere I feel like we can put
one right here and I think they'll look
really nice
so the coffee table it came with a place
I feel like it's a nice but we can like
build on top of it so my favorite like
hot drink is tea so we have this nice
tray and we can put all of our tea
accessories here and have another plant
oh my God
what I
so we have this decorative board here it
looks cute that's a nice bit of texture
to the whole thing yeah and I'm not just
seeing straight through the floor
anymore yeah and I think since we're
adding like wood tones and like more
warm tones it makes the place feel more
homey and more cozy so every time we
hang anything up especially since we're
renters we always use command strips or
anything that doesn't get us in trouble
with the landlord so these are great I
recommend 10 out of 10. we're gonna hang
something up here but I think now since
we have our plant here maybe we should
bring it in front kind of like framing
it command strips so now that the couch
is in this orientation it'd be kind of
nice to have something here to like put
your phone or a book or something yeah I
think so so we don't really have a table
but I recently saw a hack and I think we
can try it out and see if it works we
have this basket we can put a tray on
top of this and it becomes like a little
table Yeah it goes along with all the
other tones yeah I think we can put
these on top of this every bit of space
will be used
whether we like it or not
so we have a lot of books but they've
been hiding in our closet because we
don't have a bookshelf and we really
don't want to get one because we don't
have a lot of space to give a bookshelf
so we're gonna try something and see if
we can display them right here under the
TV since it's kind of like a big panel
we should fill it up with decorations
and things like that so we got a really
cool floor lamp and I think it would go
perfectly right here yeah and you have
lighting for if you want to just read it
yeah what would you call this I think
it's like a floor lamp table hybrid
so we have these really cute pillows
we're going to put this over here this
on the sofa and I feel like we can add
some to these chairs and so for a touch
of a non-beige and actually my favorite
color we have this beautiful green I
think we'll go
right here for now yeah that looks nice
reveal
[Music]
we did it and it looks amazing there's a
lot of stuff in here but it doesn't look
like there's a lot of stuff in here and
it doesn't feel like the decorations
aren't sort of encroaching on my
personal space my previous Decor which
in our other report has happened in the
past so it still has a very light Airy
feeling I really like that yeah
yeah there's also like all these sort of
softer textures and stuff like really
helps bring up that cozy feeling not
just on a visual but like when you
actually sit in the furniture and
actually experience the space the good
thing about the makeover is that
everything is renter friendly we didn't
have to make any huge you know like
changes or anything thanks to our Lord
and savior the command strips like
there's no reason this is really nice
and a lot of the decorations we have
here we can move on to other spaces and
sort of build the collection of
furniture that we already have so that's
always really nice all right guys let us
know in the comments what are your
suggestions to make a space look and
feel cozy and I hope you guys like this
video I think we should do the better
next add more beige and more candles and
make it nice
foreign
[Music]